yeah welcome to this broadcast as usual
please give me a short notice that I'm
really live yeah it happened recently
again that I wasn't so yeah welcome to
this broadcast I hope you had a good
monday so far I definitely had I've just
returned from a family birthday party
and I'm had so much dinner dinner that I
feel like not playing chess but ok let's
try and what I can do with this yeah
after a couple of non-alcoholic beers um
it's no new t-shirt no it's just what I
what I have what to dip your birthday
party ok so let's see what what we get
here having black Against the Dark
Passenger ok I want to try something
else let's go for the check benoni they
have to readjust something CSM my window
is kind of off Ian so let's see the
Latvian again yeah maybe I will play it
once I don't know we'll see this is the
old benoni i recently played that
successfully in a game so kind of
curious
hmm he's not moving yeah white has a
couple of moves now night a three Bishop
e2 Bishop d3 night of three yeah that's
that's his choice yeah I wonder I wonder
in that game that I recently had I got
in b5 quite surprisingly I wonder ever
sure to go for that or is it the wrong
approach let's try let's see if I can
get in b5 would be nice the question do
I like to play more as black as or white
hmm yeah well everybody likes white but
I don't mind that much with black you
have your chances sometimes for later in
the game yeah that's a bit a bit term
bit on the passive side my my position
here I wonder if I can check and play
five it's a bit of a strange maneuver
but interesting someone mentioned lay a
video of mine some bishop a6 moon yeah I
released videos today but I don't really
remember that move I'm sorry it's been
some time since I recorded that yeah he
can take on b6 now i'm not sure if it is
a good idea and weakens the dark squares
quite substantially maybe he still
should do that but I'm not sure yeah he
couldn't help himself and took it okay
oops I'm sorry Teague so I don't have 95
but I have night to e6 I wonder if that
is an idea maybe it is maybe not night a
6 is also possible
yeah maybe let's use this opportunity
and jump to a forum
there's an opening question someone says
they played the NIMS Oh for a while but
it's very dull hmm yeah the maid on g6
yeah that was a very nice game that I
had on my channel today yes I remember I
remember now that was quite nice yeah
unfortunately it didn't happen in the
game but it's it's good if you spot
those resources it's a good feeling even
though it didn't happen here it was was
nice to see okay so I've got the nice
night there on a4ai but what is my
actual idea and the CM hmm my bishop
only seven is really not not placed well
would like to get it over to be six it
would be queued may be here yeah someone
says the ninja was dull for him in his
in his in his games I don't think the
new minion is particularly darling I
think it depends a little bit how you
actually play it there are some lines in
the nimble that are not very exciting
but there are also others that are it's
a very versatile opening so before
giving up on the NIMS oh I'd rather say
yeah we'll check the lines that you play
is it really um yeah do you let's say
play the opening in a way that is active
enough for you you can really choose the
opening and Taylor a little bit to your
liking i'd say i'd say it's difficult to
play and let's say the lusca variation
of the Queens gambit in some kind of
aggressive fashion but the news oh it's
definitely possible so i would not so
easily give up on the opening however
you mentioned that you intend to play
kings and you know Ben Oni yeah this is
of course these are good good sharp
openings but they are entirely different
and you can combine them you can combine
them so with the Benoni for example one
thing is in the Benoni o Kings Indian
you will probably have to know more
concrete lines you can cannot yeah place
so much based on on general ideas as you
can in the NIMS Oh sometimes yeah I took
with the bish with a rope here to get
night h3n this is an immediate threat
now I've got a nice active position yeah
my bishop has activated on b6 and I'm
not quite sure what he's doing the
geroon father's black someone's
mentioned that um yeah the groom felt
well there is there are the average
books and while he is an excellent
theoretician ok this guy allowed me to
take on age 3 I don't know if you had
any big alternative to prevent it but
now this cannot be bad for me I wonder
if actually Bishop f5 is good yeah I
guess trying to fight or try to get get
to the F to pawn that looks very
problematic Bishop e2 or g2 itq form why
is the Queens gambit accepted not very
popular to be honest I don't know it's a
pretty good opening there is no
particular reason why it isn't played
there are some lines not many but some
lines that are a little bit on the
downside but really just just a couple
so I don't quite get it yeah it's a
pretty good opening if it takes on b6
now I take on b6 as well and i have f to
hanging so this should be should be fine
rookie for Bishop c5 is excellent
then there's a question how to learn an
opening line without that's not covered
in books yeah what you can try as you
can try to focus on some some games by
experts how they how they played it and
try to try to copy them try to find out
who's a big expert and just see how they
do it okay I have a nice nice position
but how am i winning I have everything
on f2 that's nice but not quite sure how
I win so Bishop Brooke Queen they're
almost ideally placed I think I probably
have to to march my pawns up so let's
get this up another idea which sounds
kind of funny but if you want to if you
don't find a book on a particular hand
you can try to write one yourself yeah
just look at the material and compile
things and you'll see that with the help
of a computer you can get very far yeah
just checking what is popular and so on
I think I can go here f3 I can't
sacrifice and this Bishop here should be
over you just has one check on b7 I
think then threatening or tons of stuff
king and queen age one King d1 this
route Queen f1 winning so that's it and
made next month yeah the check been only
struck that's nice
so um yeah the Queens gambit accepted us
of course it's okay there's nothing
particularly wrong with it what might be
a very slightly better but he is that in
many many nights a little bit um what
what variation do you recommend for
white against the Kings Indian um to be
honest against the Kings Indian it's
it's more a matter of jam it's more a
matter of chit of choosing for why to
choose one line and play it well it's
not so much what line many many lines
contain some some sort of poison and
it's just a matter of choosing what you
want for example if you play the classic
color you have to be ready to to get
attacked on the King side if you want to
yeah play in a more positional way maybe
the fianchetto system is for you there's
a huge choice why this has chances for
an advantage against the Kings Indian
with almost any line which is not mean
that the opening is bad for black it's
just that um black is risking quite a
bit strategically and you can try to
exploit it in many ways it's just a
something that you have to choose what
what to do and just learn one thing
really well to play it well
okay let's get this going PT Capri here
from this is um I think it's from Cyprus
if i'm not mistaken i don't have any
flag here so let's see probably a.m.
nope yeah we can transpose to an Enzo
but I keep it in English in English
territory someone else it's the London
system good also for non blitz hmm yeah
the London system is it's not the most
aggressive and interesting opening but
it is definitely very solid um of course
I mean you can play it it's um it's a
very healthy opening the problem a
little bit with the London system is it
strategically quite limited so it is not
leading to a huge variety of positions
or two to very reality it's not very
interesting generally it kind of is the
same in in in many many games and if you
it's not a great opening to to expand
your horizons let's say in chess
learning of new worm let's say porn
structures or or something yeah it's
more gel it's a it's more of a practical
weapon let's say it's it's easy to play
you can develop easily but it's it's not
very very very exciting it's often used
by stronger players and blitz chess
because you can usually wheel out dash
out the first move so quickly which is
helpful but it's not that they think
they have an advantage jam it's just
that they want to get a game going
without having to let me to risk
anything yet but should be five I
thought we should see for here but i can
actually maybe really take em yeah but
ok let's do that
um okay so you went to Knight to f6 huh
interesting so okay I cannot say I can
check on d6 and look see one maybe I got
i geti five now as a good square from a
night but I had to prepare that 92 was
was annoying interesting position here
maybe be five is a move but I know it's
okay someone for the greenford
recommends the book the sea safest
gruene felt by delchev an arrest yeah
that's okay it's less threatening I mean
threatening is the wrong word but if you
want to take the books by by by
grandmaster a brook there are two books
totaling over to one-half 1000 pages on
the Greenfeld and this is very difficult
to learn it's just so much material so
many pages okay 95 runs in 292 so I
shouldn't do that okay let's go here
that's a good strategic move anyway I
just wonder about Luke takes before I
hope that's not leading into some kind
of ugly pin um there's a question how do
i structure my lessons yeah it's not
easy to say it really depends a lot on
the level of the player the one asking
is less it's 1850 yeah I would
definitely look at your games and try to
make some kind of profile what you what
you do well what you don't do so well
and trying to structure the lesson some
recording to that it's also a matter of
if you have a kind of sort of short-term
go along some particular idea what you
want to do in the lessons because it's
also matter of what you feel um yeah
what you feel is useful and I want to
address things that yeah
something that you feel are pressing
it's not just me choosing what is right
but also but also looking at things that
the student feels is is useful for him
what is this he's attacking f2 they're
interesting huh it's difficult to defend
this hmm rook f1 that looks very passive
and he might have night it takes f2 with
this night EF to look after mmm and it's
working I don't get it I'm not sure not
sure about this I 92 we can play he can
play 92 I want a nice trick 92 Wow job
that's it I saw that too late hmm solid
too late yeah that's a cute trick sure
if i take i made it on h2 i really don't
have any hair don't have a move them wow
that was cute ok next game yeah the
Grandmaster repertoire books for 1800
players are simply am simply too much it
is useless I mean they are to mean the
books are great in a technical sense but
it's not you cannot simply m you cannot
learn that money lines it's the same I
cannot use those books really I mean and
they are essentially written for for for
my playing strength and I have problems
such as too much so um it's it's mostly
for reference purposes yeah you can look
things up and then stuff like that ok I
playing z Rafa who is that is that
let me check us coal burner that some
scuba know that's a Slovenian player I
think there's a question is easier for
me to teach a 1400 or 2200 player um-hmm
it's difficult to say actually it's
difficult to say I think cam it depends
on the 2200 player a little bit what
exactly his strengths and weaknesses are
in some cases it can be quite um yeah it
can be can be very hard work to find
suitable exercises for a player of that
strength for the 1400 player is some
it's easier to find self find out what
to do but it's some sometimes not so
easy to get into the mindset of 1400
player for 2200 that's easier but it has
it pros and cons I like to do both
really
there's a question would shyness vie
here each 2800 in the next two years
yeah I think he probably would be very
disappointed with himself if he doesn't
when if you get get to that level the
level that he has um with how is he's 15
years old I think you definitely want to
set the goals around that level but I
cannot really tell you because well as I
answered in earlier sessions it's I
never studied his games really I mean
it's obviously very strong but I cannot
even tell you what kind of player he is
okay we got a modern been only here
against this guy mr. Scoob a low score
burner I don't know Scoob Anya problem
um and don't know he gave up his light
squared Bishop which I am Not sure was a
good idea and the light squares that he
has a kind of weak however my bishop 1 H
2 also makes a somewhat silly impression
or in all the typically murky benoni
position I want to play rookie one here
getting on the e-file the question
what's my ovarian of this opening but II
for Air Force oh you mean the timing of
a techie 4f form I don't know I don't
know what the current evaluation is but
it's quite clear that many top GM so
they they don't go for they don't go for
that anymore that that pawns three pawns
attack and quite often there is a reason
why people avoid lines so maybe I'm the
the somewhat more restraint setups I'm
warm yeah promising at the moment I'm
playing this night a three base set up
mostly because I can get get to this
from various move water center I think
one should have an idea three based
system against the Benoni ready at least
okay um what about rookie six that looks
like you want to play it but rookie six
txtx Queen takes now that looks good
let's put this in against lots of
champion and activates everything okay
surprising Oh a can FYI saying I just
blundered f4 that's not a good idea my
position was excellent before hmm not
good not good at all I came her stupid
it was stupid okay I can take f4 and
take f5 let's do that that's really not
what I had planned but ok it's still
it's still not a it's still not bad for
me because of the the bishop pan but it
was wasn't really what I wanted so
Bishop to see three would be great do I
get get it down Bishop a choice awesome
this will each form Knight f6 rook a3 is
pretty good I think where's he going to
e form job so I have g45 maybe or look
f3 that's not leading to that much
and maybe let's do that keeps us pieces
a bit pinned g4 age six kids not leading
to can't a group g3 but it's not helping
okay I did yeah that's cool yeah oops
not pre moving that please what is shame
and it was a it was a good position
really i really had a good position here
yeah i am after after such a such
extensive denier playing chess is always
took you for me i know that
I wonder what he's doing I can industry
can go we'll just he can just go to we
eat right is there a huge problem with
that I don't see it I always jumping is
going there
don't don't quite understand the point
but he has trapped his own night but
okay it's still winning but i don't i
don't really get it King g6 bishop fri
few chapters all night he could have
gone to we aid of course he's still
winning but it's a kind of strange so um
yeah 685 him not much I can do about
yeah okay I need a new game yet there
was a bit too murky disposition it was
really great yeah before i blundered all
that stuff around here black is just in
bad shape he's just having weaknesses on
e6 f5 and so on that's a bad position
for black but I really played it badly
really badly for example I'm what
happened here Luke he really I should
probably go Bishop f2 first cover d4 and
then continue but okay we don't do heavy
analysis here ah so what we are my way
okay let's do what can i play against
him that I didn't try my way from Norway
he played many scotches I wanted to I
want to do something else here let's go
for modern defense Wow g4 okie dokie
just lashes out with g4 okay if he goes
gee for I go be five Andrew k 7 that's
probably too much okay maybe c6f I don't
know if I was a very early aggression Oh
what the heck so I'm going to attack his
pawns there
wow what a position so he takes it ok
can I always think it's cool if you have
a position after eight moves that in the
hood history of chess probably never has
occurred he and why not let the end
that's a good idea ya think I think you
should I should should I go for that
right yeah I've I forgot about it
actually he would be a good candidate to
play the Latvian against because um
because um he's a very sharp player
anyway never play the Latvian it's
probably like it's probably like waving
a red flag in front of a bull okay let's
go back there is out for each five wow
okay I have to have to somehow patch the
center and now develop I think that's
not too bad if he takes g6 Bishop g6
it's kind of ok I hope I hope
hmm what a strange position yeah he's
taking his time but that's kind of
normal he's not a very fast player so
considering his options so yep Kim let's
go here
my king yeah every time I play the
modern defends I feel what did I do to
my king what has he done to deserve this
yeah okay yeah i will get ever played
the Latvian I just forgot about it I
will play it once hi to the internet
chess club account
at least I'm head on the clock in this
position that's the only real good news
here I'm trying to Castle long and maybe
Knight b6 to see fine also as useful
he's a really dangerous player I mean
I'm down two points here my score is not
great I've got ten and a half out of 23
against him so I'm I'm won't let's see
yeah I send oh I know okay wait to be 6
i'm not sure about this with hindsight
if it was a good idea okay let's get get
the King out of there cannot stay there
all the time and he played king f2 in
response cool um so what am I going to
go here I haven't played c5 he ever
that's not good Queen over here
wonderfest Queen he might sacrifice on
be fire
I really don't know what to do here I
don't like my position at all looks very
shaky and you might be able to take on
b5 but Knight to f5 as my idea my still
you can take on b5 I simply don't do
anything about it okay maybe like see
takes Knight takes a B if it doesn't
look good it does not look good play and
play lugo 6 as well well okay so let's
get need to get my concentration level
up here do want to lose every game so
night f 595 maybe a for the entering on
g3 yeah that's okay you can do that
you're not threatening much now what
about to Bishop f5 a bishop h5 here
should age 54 Queen g3 okay let's do
that look you three days bishop f3
Luke g8 we should be two minutes that's
an extra piece if I'm not completely
completely wrong so look h2 now enter
King somewhere king you 1 then we are
Quincy eight maybe and let's do that
first and now Quincy eight or anything
else night xe3 even is interesting night
xe3
how save defending that 93 Russia a drug
g8 threatening queen jou daar ook g1
made Queen takes rook a2g 24 h one made
take stings checks I can can actually go
back with the king okay that trends
Quincy to and the night hangs there was
much easier move but I thought night XD
3 i'll take it group takes a one mate so
let's take hear the good news is that
this is a really relatively safe
position my king is quite safe yep but I
can do I can take I can really take it
let's see how am i meeting him here
forum PM probably should be too much
f5 mmm don't tell me I have no chick
made here that's probably enough and now
mmm i think i just take it yep Oh still
a bit annoying
okay so let's let's go to let's play it
actively I'm not trying to hunker down
queen bee to hear ya but I can take
right you can get a new queen but this
is not going to end well where's the
maid there must be a maid somewhere okay
he lost some time but okay that's three
pawns and I'm going to meet him somehow
okay someone says the wall you missed
quite low no I don't think so I really
don't think I never change any set up
here so it should be should be okay
really should be okay the volume maybe
try to turn up the church volume okay so
I have to check some questions what do I
think about the semis laughs yeah but
what's one of the total main lines and
obviously very good opening so go ahead
with it if you like it it's a good
opening with black semi Slav so we got
the Kings Indian maybe your modern
defense get a modern defense actually
yeah this line is some sometimes plate
but it is not particularly great let's
see what we get here yeah I cannot also
take now
I wonder yeah let's take that's a an
easy relatively easy way to play it and
now Bishop h5 check he has to move is
king and therefore so black has some
coordination issues now let's see what
happens is king had to move and yes he
can play King f7 but it still kind of
uncoordinated so white has various ideas
I can try to play with this and i think
i'm going to go for that i can play for
g4 but c5 is quick if i get it in
quickly let's do that I don't know does
he really play on the G file here he
maybe we'll know let's have a look at b7
yeah the blue shirt cause your eyes to
bleed ok so I'm attacking b7 here and
let's see what you will do Jim I don't
know i also have taken on d6 and attack
that horn like here quinchu before or
something now let's take I don't want to
spend a long time on that chair I have
played this guy before and usually the
biggest problem was some time issue not
the not the position i usually got get
good positions but then screw it up on
on on time issues so i'm trying to play
quick Queenie eight now i don't think i
want to trade queens here necessarily
let's do this I might have Queens sex I
seem that could be an idea so Queen a
795 yes i see ok that's a good move
actually hmm yeah I don't want him to
take on d5 really I don't have a good
square for my formula for my bishop yep
so I'm going back at least them he had
to weaken c6 in the process
yeah so he's going on to g2 yeah maybe
maybe here I mean g3 he's got h5 coming
yep it's not so clear this position I
don't know my god rooks is six and rooks
is seven and so on but you can maybe
attack my pawn there on d5 hmm here we
go
Oh
Bishop g4 that's night you form a Bishop
c4 I mean that's not your phone
look the one is like most passive move
ever but Bishop c4 energy for also looks
kind of wrong gooks e6e place rook 28
simply
hmm
yeah passive but I want to regroup him
maybe maybe that's a lemon lemon kind of
move but i was thinking of regrouping no
less that's what i wanted to put the
bishop on c6 maybe that's completely
wrong yeah it feels a bit wrong now I
played that belly it's just not good
chess my pieces are wrong
I don't know night 2 g-3 is not not
whatever food I expected but anyway it
just missed places the night but ok and
I said I hardly ever understand any
office moves and quite often I'm losing
so let's see what happens here just get
attack on the queenside him his night
blocks G file I don't know I don't know
yeah someone said they watched my
coverage from yesterday's yeah thanks
for head was I was a good good fun good
fun coverage of that icc open the only
gas is not playing at that time of day
he just not his not his time so it's
very unlikely that we ever get to see a
game on the live stream that i have
against him my name is this yes OD gas
is said shuffle and play the clock guy
exactly that okay so let's see is
probably going to get rook g7 in and i'm
going to cover here and then we'll see
if he has if you find some chick made or
not I have b4 b5 b6 and promotion so he
has to check made me someone has a
problem yet exactly with the stream you
should really just try to refresh the
whole thing and hope it gets better it's
really not much that I can do so b5 in
my to take only 3
I am not sure if I see how I'm losing
this I don't I don't see it at the
moment O'Quinn be six is there something
no one not really also threatens queen d
8 so a seven
I don't I don't see it really I think
I'm just covering everything yeah it
feels unlikely that something's going to
happen now as his as he had had to give
him give the whole the whole look down
who in here for Queenie 6 or queen f5 if
possible okay if I take here let's go
just for modem take f5 is there
something I don't see it I simply don't
see it okay for what exactly mmm Queen
g3 out for Queen g3 start with that
check here they always have rookie to
okay yeah so we resigned yeah I managed
to fight that off whoo okay so what do
we do we have can't you have a specialty
classes on no not going to ask him I'm
not going to ask him yeah you know it's
quite funny I recently checked I mean I
got dislikes on my I got dislikes on my
videos on the channel everybody does
that right but i did a statistic where
my disclose dislikes are coming from and
the second look at the country with the
second-most dislikes i get is actually
latvia we're only gas is from so I
really suspect is dis liking my videos
so it gets kind of funny or maybe some
can German of him but it's really a
statistical total weirdness because i
only get dislikes from latvia it's
really cool ok so um I got an old Indian
him against cahors catch-all and let's
see I can't have ok 95 it's kind of a
bit annoying why did I do that I
shouldn't have played d5 her twin situ
is wrong that's not wrong but it's not
what I wanted to do no it's okay
83 Bishop e3 yeah maybe he really has
multiple YouTube dislikes and accounts
to dislike me I don't know okay some
questions here sometimes a bit tricky to
to get get to read all the questions
simply kind of its not very um that's
not not easily readable that chat window
okay do we get the he's playing here for
f 5m very aggressive way to play here ha
so going for f4 maybe he is okay I'm
going to take it go for beef or beef one
night if he 494 should be okay and FYI
think I can I thought I can take see
fire but i'm not sure about it oh maybe
if i take c 595 snps Bishop f5
out for B form that's a question how do
i how i replace my passive chick or
inline yeah i haven't replaced it yet
really no time so what now hmm form and
f1 both coming let's see not sure yet
about f form that is so dangerous maybe
it is yeah i can always play the brea
right i mean it's it's an it's an
opening line that if the if the opponent
is not exactly a super expert in the in
the way you you can play the Bram even
with very general knowledge yeah I
wonder what he's doing now he is he
going for F or is he going for F form is
he playing a prep move he's simply not
playing ok so here I really have to go
to h2 not much else to do and if it goes
f4 I have to go to see one and then he
can go F 3 yeah but I don't know that
this might be a bit much yeah I have to
have looked at the site itself and I'm
not sure about this line it's it's
certainly not bad it's just not clear to
me if it suits my style ok he takes
there yeah the site the site safe can
get very very sharp at times and it's in
some cases black skin gets under under
fire quite a bit which is always
something that I try to avoid ok I'm
taking here if it takes with the bishop
I think ok
testing I thought Bishop f4 now is quite
good yeah it's a good position now I
have Bishop d3 coming and I can attack
the airfryer porn it seems quite good
for white I thought you would take with
the dip on yeah how do i define my style
yeah I know that I need to save King and
I don't get that in the sides have quite
often so this is why I'm objective in a
little bit to that idea but it's not a
bad opening of course as I itself
zaitsev variation in the in the Spanish
okay um I wonder what is this I can take
and go nitey for if everything else
fails so let's do that I checking c5 and
everything where is he going i get i get
to a nice square there to g5 for example
maybe he can go queen bee six it's not
it's not the end of the world okay i
played this oh here i can take a c5 huh
efore I'm sucking the piece that that's
too much I think this is too much on
blacks on blacks position I've got a ton
of pawns and he's got rook a 897 and
everything that cannot be right so I can
check here for the next pawn and snow
what's now here I am 44 look at 7i guess
yeah it's too much it was really too
much he has his pieces are in the corner
brook a six maybe he can go look a six I
forgot about that move yes Luke a six
year mm not good
yeah I can't let's go him
tetany woke age seven Bishop f7 and so
on
yeah maybe it was a bit i played this a
bit quickly o.o that may be but I simply
cannot believe he holds this it's kind
of uncoordinated yeah i resigned i can
take h3 now that looked pretty pretty
decent ok so next game going isn't the
zaitsev for theoretical nightmare whom i
don't i don't know i mean the thing is
ok i have that book by yohance on that
you managed no I'm not afraid that
people have the stream running in the
background it's just for fun anyway I
mean I have had sessions where I lost
all of the games and it's it you should
just be cool about it it's just such as
blitz chess what can you do ok I didn't
get the Latvian in the stream is delayed
about 20 20 seconds the twitch delay
yeah I requested a new game but I didn't
get it hmm maybe I can get the Latvian n
I get it in this guy's going here for
vulvar een here we go hey it is the
Latvian gambit let's see what he's doing
against it and one thing is ok he takes
it that's not very common but don't ask
me why ok so i push this and now see
what happens so these six it's not that
bad actually that could have been worse
it feels like a relatively normal
position now ok i know it's guy despise
playing every move instantly without any
kind of consideration every game so why
do that here um Bishop f7 maybe I have
to probably cover g5 capturing on d5 is
just wrong but ok gives me this is 666
square so let's see immediately or not
96 I mean I've attacking deform ok let's
do that first and then go knight c6 just
attacking d for now Wow ok I take the
big sent upon if you insist I take it
and he basically insisted so
where do you go with that night buddy so
this is the Latvian gambit right leg
gets an extra point in the center to
center pawns rolling what a position
unbelievable yeah it was very very
helpful of course very helpful to my
course so let's see how do i how do I
actually convert that and d 394 many
many possible moves yeah
I don't know at many good moves it's
your it's it's it's awesome you're
spoiled for choice yeah it's so nice for
Bishop b3 so just be sure PA are keeping
keeping the d3 porn and then maybe
Knight g4 yep he prevented that so ok
now I should have maybe prevented this
bishops e3 stuff it could have been I
could have had an easier life here i
guess but ok the the d3 point is just
very strong
crystal on the e farm is good I cannot
play the Latvian against mr. williger's
because he plays Knight f3 193 every
move and he's not going for one year for
I have tried many things against him I
tried the Kings gambit is wide and
failed miserably because he has some
very dry and pretty good lines against
it he's a good theoretical player so um
okay to what is the point here in
kitchen let's do that rook g3 I take was
his back rank is quite weak and if he
has to if he has to remove the Queen i'm
going to go d 2
yeah now he lets the clock run down this
sets SML mo he plays the first ten moves
in eight seconds then blunders something
and then at the end he lets the clock
run down and know that already okay so
let's wait what happens oh the your
games ravit wow what the your games
reviewed serious what about this yes yes
yes yes I'm actually releasing a video
of them tomorrow probably tomorrow or on
Wednesday I disconnected info fates okay
yeah that's also happening sometimes
okay next game ya ever is true with that
guy okay and let's see what happens in
the next game oh it's already 11 11 my
time I already don't pay attention much
to the clock one hour's already already
am past but ok I will I will release it
like in a couple of hours let's say
while the day after that this the days
are very confusing it tuesday the second
of june or wednesday the third probably
so what happens do i get yet another
game I think it's okay at all i kept my
rating in that session let's have a
brief check there I lost 22 games early
on but gained a couple of wins after
that that's cool and you can send games
in yes but have such a huge backlog
there why don't I get a game going I've
tried but summer I don't get a pairing
yeah there's actually some action down
the five-minute poet there's some
moskalenko playing and some some good
some good players on but I don't get
paired penguin okay I'm going if or in
the hope for some kind of funky opening
here we go be three against them against
the events of French yeah this is a
strange line I know people played that
against me when I was black and I always
thought wow that must be complete
rubbish but now I am tried it a bit and
I know it leads to very strange
positions that I'm in fact sometimes
difficult for black to handle so let's
see what we get in this is this game
it's not that I believe much in that but
it's a it leads to something else let's
let's put it like that it's a very
different from usual French positions
huh he takes a long while here a 60 ok
let's try to attack the center here ok
closed it down interesting hmm yo maybe
I can provoke the night to be six so
that he cannot easily play b5 ok he does
not want that it seems but Queenie 7 is
also not the most natural with ever so I
don't mind that much not before as a
move that can be irritating I think I go
actually let me play Bishop e2 to
discourage age 6 let's do that now here
and put the bishop on the long diagonal
that cannot be so bad what a weird
position them what a weird position
let's go here so after age 69 age form I
have g5 prevented yep so let's go here
so yeah it sets a bit different from my
usual chest but it's quite interesting
and I don't have a bad position here I
really don't think Queen a 8 kind of a
direct threat so III and can i play
before is that too much I don't know III
yeah maybe want to develop my way night
that sometimes he cannot take age for
all right he can maybe I think he could
have taken the pawn but not anymore so
now I have 95 but he could have taken
one move earlier I think okay so what is
he going for its night before I don't
know queen is protected so he doesn't
have any great tactic if he takes so his
King side is going to be very weak so
let's let's break that open them doesn't
look good for black he has very little
counter play and I just play on the King
side yep someone mentioned my bishop
won't be too is kind of strange that's
true but everything else is great yeah
you know the King side is great oh wow
want to move I can't take the hiss
naughty five so i have to start with
that one
so that f5 Assange was check take it was
check that looks really really wrong for
black rook f8 maybe is coming with
rookie evade huh but still if I go g6
isn't that just going to be great rook
f8 rook f h+ even g7 and i have Queenie
form that's also stopping any kind of
counter play
yeah just a great position for what okay
ever check on aah he has the night and
night retreat just not great or anything
but still I me I can go here that sets
actually ok I can still check you here
hmm my check on a eight it's got King to
disarm ok let's give that check yeah my
not my mind my not playing a bishop
there is kind of is a concern wonder if
I should just go and let's go g7 come on
don't want to take even more time night
f42 air night f 46 would be good I
wanted to push the Pont first and limit
him he really has a hard time to move
any of its pieces there
I'm gonna do much yeah there are some
people here requesting some openings and
what I want to say is I had this this
opening challenge yeah and this is
coming up in June where we'll play em
openings different from what I usually
do and I have continued this with
different themed weeks that will come up
in in june and july i have done some
things like the fianchetto weekly aware
play g3 rg6 every game i have played
them a week with what was it i have got
one offbeat week where i was really
playing totally off bid openings it was
much fun some openings that i never
played before in my life hey i have
played them what else did I do yeah this
is it mostly the offbeat week was the
was the coolest so I'm yeah look forward
to that going to be released in june and
july so the final thing is i need to get
let's take that you to get my bishop
into the game I actually queen age seven
would have been better I guess right
okay it's not a not a big deal so nine
up let's use all pieces is he
threatening anything I don't see it look
f7 maybe I just got the check here on
edge too hmm that's true
so maybe just this for age 6 I tried to
play the pond siani I didn't get it I
simply didn't get it I mean people
didn't play you five
what happens now he's a ticking age 60
no I don't give you that one here yeah
attacking f4i blundered that but I have
rook f7 so it's it's not not really a
cause for concern I'm just meeting him
here yeah and he resigned yes you
resigned yet it's sometimes a bit tricky
because i don't have the resins sound
okay so i think it was a was a good
session today i played quite quite well
concerning that I feel like a stuffed
turkey after that after that dinner okay
cool I hope you enjoyed that and i
managed to answer a couple of questions
there um yeah i'll be back on next
Monday and next monday might be the
final one for a couple of for two or
three weeks because I be off on vacation
but make sure to tune in next Monday
same time 10 um 10 in the evening
central european time or four in the
afternoon u.s. East Coast thanks for
watching guys bye
you